J'avais 23 ans
quand j'ai entendu parler de la justice reproductive.
Je travaillais pour un magazine féminin
où j'ai appris que Sister Song définissait la justice reproductive comme étant :
une : le droit d'une femme de décider si et quand elle aura un bébé
et les conditions dans lesquelles elle donnera naissance.
Deux : le droit d'une femme de décider si elle ne veut pas avoir de bébé
et ses options pour éviter ou mettre un terme à une grossesse.
Et trois : le droit d'une femme d'être une mère pour les enfants qu'elle a déjà
dans des environnements sûrs et sains
sans craindre de violence
de la part d'individus ou du gouvernement.
J'ai toujours voulu être une mère.
En grandissant, j'ai tout entendu sur les joies de la maternité.
Je rêvais de voir mon ventre mettre une merveille au monde.
Je savais que j'étais jeune.
Mais je me disais
que cela ne pouvait pas faire de mal de prévoir une chose si importante si tôt.
Mais maintenant,
j'ai 26 ans.
Et j'ignore si j'ai ce qu'il faut pour encaisser la maternité dans ce pays.
Au fil des années, l'Amérique m'en a appris plus sur la parentalité
qu'aucun livre sur le sujet.
Comment certaines femmes donnent naissance à des bébés
et d'autres à des suspects.
Que ce corps donnera naissance à une famille
qui a plus de chance d'être détenue dans des cellules
que d'obtenir des diplômes universitaires.
Il y a quelque chose quand on est noire en Amérique
qui fait paraître la maternité
compliquée.
Il semble
que j'ignore quoi faire pour bien élever mes enfants
et les garder en vie.
Dis-je à mon fils de ne pas voler car c'est mal
ou car ils s'en serviront pour justifier sa mort ?
Lui dis-je
que même s'il paie ses bonbons et son thé,
il y en aura quand même qui l'observeront
et verront un criminel avant un enfant ;
qui appelleront la police et n'attendront pas son arrivée.
Est-ce que je veux que la police vienne ?
Des coups de feux mortels résonnent quand j'envisage d'appeler la police.
Je ne prendrais pas pour acquis le fait qu'ils ne viennent pas tuer mon fils.
Nous nous sommes débarrassés des potences,
mais c'est du lynchage quand ils assassinent des garçons noirs
et laissent leur corps durant quatre heures au soleil.
Un rappel historique :
il y a quelque chose quand on est noire en Amérique
qui fait sonner la maternité
comme un deuil.
Je pourrais me réveiller un matin
et voir mon fils en boucle aux informations.
Je pourrais me réveiller et réaliser
que la mort de ma fille n'est pas digne des informations.
Vous ne pouvez pas me dire que Sandra Bland est la seule femme noire
dont la violence mérite plus que notre silence.
Qu'en est-il de nos autres sœurs à peau foncée en détresse
dont nous devons encore honorer la mort ?
Et de nos enfants
dont les vies ne tiennent pas entre les limites de vos genres ?
Apparemment, rien ne vous protège vraiment
si vous venez dans un corps qui ressemble à ceci.
Il y a quelque chose quand on est noire en Amérique
qui fait de la maternité
une chose pour laquelle je ne suis pas impatiente.
J'ai écrit trop de poèmes sur des enfants noirs morts pour être naïve
quant au fait qu'il pourrait y avoir un jour un poème écrit sur mes enfants.
Mais je ne veux pas être une mère donnant naissance à des poèmes.
Je ne veux pas d'une strophe comme fils
ou d'une ligne comme petite fille
ou d'une note en bas de page comme enfant n'ayant pas sa place dans ce monde.
Non.
Je ne veux pas d'enfants qui vivront pour toujours
dans les pages de la poésie,
mais ne peuvent pas vivre
plus longtemps que moi.
(Applaudissements)
J'ai été invitée à la conférence TEDWomen
pour réciter un poème.
Mais pour moi, la poésie n'est pas qu'un art et une performance.
C'est une forme de protestation.
Hier,
durant la répétition,
on m'a dit qu'il y avait eu
deux ou trois talks TED au sujet de Black Lives Matter.
Que je devrais peut-être réduire mon intervention
pour ne traiter « que » de justice reproductive.
Mais ce poème et ce talk
ont fondamentalement pour sujet mon incapacité à séparer les deux.
J'avais 21 ans --
(Applaudissements)
J'avais 21 ans quand Trayvon Martin a été assassiné.
Trayvon Martin, un garçon noir de 17 ans,
un enfant noir,
m'a rappelé,
nous a rappelé
le peu de valeur que cette nation place dans une vie noire.
Le hashtag #BlackLivesMatter
est devenu l'appel le plus reconnu
pour que les gens noirs et nos enfants
vivent dans des environnements sûrs et des communautés saines
sans craindre
de violence de la part d'individus, de l'État ou du gouvernement.
Des mois plus tard,
quand George Zimmerman n'a pas été tenu reponsable
du meurtre de Trayvon Martin,
j'ai entendu Sybrina Fulton,
la mère de Trayvon Martin, parler.
Son témoignage m'a affectée si profondément
que je me suis constamment demandé
ce que cela signifierait d'être une mère en Amérique dans cette peau.
Que signifie réellement la maternité
quand, pour tant de gens qui me ressemblent,
elle est synonyme de deuil ?
Sans le réaliser,
j'avais commencé à associer la notion de justice reproductive
et du mouvement pour les vies noires.
En en apprenant plus sur la justice reproductive
au magazine où j'étais
et en continuant d'être active dans le mouvement pour les vies noires,
j'ai voulu que les autres voient et ressentent ces similitudes.
Je me suis demandé :
de qui est-ce le rôle à une telle époque
de relier des idées, des réalités et les gens ?
Je veux dédicacer ce talk et ce poème
à Constance Malcolm.
C'est la mère de Ramarley Graham
qui était un autre enfant noir
assassiné avant son heure.
Elle m'a rappelé lors d'un dîner,
alors que je luttais pour écrire ce poème,
que c'est le rôle de l'artiste
de déterrer les histoires que les gens essayent d'enterrer
avec les pelles de la complaisance et du temps.
Récemment,
Toni Morrison a écrit :
« Dans des moments d'effroi,
les artistes ne doivent jamais choisir de garder le silence.
Il n'y a pas le temps de s'apitoyer,
pas de place pour la peur. »
Hier, durant la répétition,
quand on m'a dit que je devrais
« supprimer la partie de mon intervention sur Black Lives Matter »,
cela a été un moment effrayant pour moi.
Effrayant que l'on refuse à nouveau à nos histoires
les scènes sur lesquelles elles méritent d'être.
Puis je me suis souvenue des mots que je venais de prononcer.
« Dans des moments d'effroi,
les artistes ne doivent jamais choisir de garder le silence.
Il n'y a pas le temps de s'apitoyer.
(Applaudissements)
Et pas de place pour la peur. »
Et j'ai fait mon choix.
Et je fais toujours mon choix.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)